Hello everyone, how are you? This is Jyn
with Next Level Commander and we are not
even done with these mystery boosters
yet, but ah reality fracture is already
out and these are delicious. Holy crap.
I I'm Yeah, I've got months of content
lined up. But but the first legend we
are looking at here is actually Tam the
possibility, which is interesting
because the generic fivecolor commander
is usually the last thing I look at when
going through a set. And also super
friends, that's something I got bored of
10 years ago. So why Tam isn't her
glorious hair? Yeah, it's pretty
enticing. Oh, imagine the possibil. Oh,
she's a Gorgon, isn't she? Ah, crap. But
seriously though, five color planes
walkers in 2026 is got to be something
special. And honestly, I think it is cuz
Tam enables a kind of deck that I I want
to call aggro Planaineswalkers. No,
we're not beating people up with
Gideonss, but what we're doing here is
we are trying to amass a bunch of
emblems as fast as we can. Some pretty
useless, but it's okay. We're doing
quantity over quality here. And I'm sure
you've been advised to never bank on a
planaineswalker ultimating. But here we
are turning that on its head and we are
playing some planaineswalkers that are
otherwise pretty useless. We are just
here for the alt like baseret for
example. We don't need pump. We're not
attacking with anything until that
ultimate goes off of course. So yeah,
normally super friends decks are seen as
oppressive, kind of boring to play
against. It's almost like a combo deck
where you, you know, try to get one of
those alts off and the game's over.
We're trying not to do that. But we're
taking these smaller, less dominant
emblem effects and kind of using them as
permanent buffs. And trust me, you will
need these buffs as you get later into
the game with these, you know, lower
quality individual cards. So, the
promise has been made and you are
interested. How do we go about this?
Once again, how do I deliver on the
clickbaity thumbnail? Well, well, I did
achieve this once in the early testing
days with the help of a birds of
paradise. So we had Tam on turn two and
we dropped two planes walkers on turn
three and activated TM and ultimated
both planaineswalkers on turn four. Now
the alts are pretty mediocre especially
Rowan salt. I used it I think once in
the entire game but that was cool. It
felt like I was doing something broken
but it wasn't too oppressive. I mean I
didn't win that game so I wanted to do
it again and I realized the key to doing
that is being one turn faster with these
turn one manadors. So, we are playing
every single one mana rem option that is
available including birds, including
elves, whatever, even wild growth. And
the next part of our plan is the three
mana planaineswalkers. And we are not
picky. A lot of these planes walkers
just don't see play at all. But why not?
We can play them. Yeah, this alt seems
decent, but there are a few that are
actually excellent. The new blue
chandra, for example, she does a lot of
things. The survey is very likely to
draw as a card and that ramp ability is
just incredible. We can't use it to
activate temp, but being able to drop
Shandra and then a four drop planes
walker on turn three is yeah is amazing.
I've done it once and I look forward to
the next time so much. And the alt is
also really good. Yeah, this is the
complete package. Another one that is
really similar is Ren and the
Realmreaker. Every single ability here
is relevant. The plus one, the static,
and the ultimate especially. Yeah,
having one of these in the opening hand
and we are about to have an excellent
game. Also, Rowan, I know I made fun of
her earlier, but her alt happens really
easily. And also when we need the
backside is also pretty good, especially
the draw two option. There are also a
few planes walkers here that don't make
emblems, but their ultimates are
interesting. Yeah, they're definitely
useful. And for example, an early ashok
can cause a lot of chaos. But my
favorite one though is definitely a
Johnny Outland Chaperel. And the first
two abilities are not terrible, but this
ultimate, this ultimate is why I play
this game, man. And it's so perfect for
this deck. I haven't done it yet, but
you know, I'll be pushing for it every
game I play. Okay, so aside from these,
we have a few honorary three drops.
These are the ones that cost a little
bit extra, but they ramp us also. So, we
can still carry out our turn one, turn
two, turn three, turn four curve without
skipping a beat. The first one is Narset
of the Ancient Way. Solid abilities
ramps us and also a really fair emblem,
just perfect for this deck. Shandra,
Torch of Defiance. The double red can be
pretty awkward, but even if it doesn't
ramp us this turn, it's going to help a
lot in the next turn. Defairy, who slows
the sunset, untaps a manador, and untaps
a land. Yeah, with Defairy we can play
two four drops on turn three. But the
ferryy isn't even the best one. That
spot goes to Dada. This card is so
pushed. I even suspect it being a design
mistake. Pay four, play Dada, and get
four treasures back. Yeah, and that's
the floor. You can just also dig for
legendary planaineswalkers if you want
to. Yeah, this is probably the single
best card in the deck. Okay, and there
you have it. This is the core of the
deck. Roughly 20 or so cards, and the
goal is to ultimate these planes walkers
as soon as we can, but we're also
leaving some room for the fun stuff. and
also backup plants. Let's start with the
fun stuff. But yeah, the fun stuff in a
planainwalker deck is just more
planaineswalkers. But we get to choose
which ones we like at least. For
example, commander Guff. I've always
wanted to play this card and it's
perfect here. Also, Tofairy, Master of
Time. Such a fun and unique planer
design. One of the few that is made for
multiplayer. And also the big Tfairy.
Yeah, untapping four lands is huge here.
I do have to be careful though. I think
I have four Tfaries in the deck. And
remember, Tam cares about unique
planaineswalker types. So, we might have
to make some adjustments if that becomes
a problem. Also, the new Ajani. It is
not perfect for this deck, but it's got
decent synergy. Most of the abilities
are relevant. So, yeah, seems fun. And
also, the new Jace cuz yeah, this card
is ridiculous in EDH. I don't know why
they don't make more multiplayer
oriented planes walkers. They do it for
every other card type. So, this seems
like a decent start, but then they're
going to take it too far and yeah, we
just we can't have good things. So,
well, we'll see. So, aside from the ramp
options, we also do need some other
support for our game plan. The biggest
one, of course, is backup and protection
for our commander. I'm playing all these
free ones because of how tight our
manner curve is. But if the TAM plan
falls apart, we do have a lot of other
ways to surprise alt our planes walker.
Because again, if you played or played
against super friends, you will know the
best way to al planes walkers is to do
it when people don't expect you to. It
could be all of a sudden proliferating a
bunch onto the walkers. It could be when
they should be dying to combat, you face
them out and they come back with an
extra counter to alt. Having an extra
activation is definitely good. And of
course, doubling season. Oh, and also my
favorite extra turn spell, savor the
moment. This card is broken in a
planaineswalker deck. It's it's just
explore for one extra mana, but you get
one more activation on everything. Dream
tide will is also cool. This one is
telegraphed, but it makes things super
awkward for your opponents. They have to
kill the whale or they have to decide
between enabling you or limiting their
spells. It's also just a massive body.
It's another sweet design I've always
wanted to play with. And just a few
other pieces of utility. Oath of Nissa
is amazing. I wish I could tutor for it
every game. We do have problem manifing.
We'll talk about this later. And also
Gias Phoenix. This card is not necessary
in the deck, but it's such great value.
We're often casting multiple planes
walkers a turn. And it can just copy our
alt, right? If we make an emblem, now we
make two. And board wipes. We do have
decent spot removals from our planes
walkers. So, we are focusing our removal
cards on board wipes. Of course, we also
have a few of these walkers, but in a
plan walker deck, yes, we need to
destroy all creatures. We don't want to
be too oppressive with it, but without
board wipes, we are going to lose our
planaineswalkers every turn basically.
So, we need to kill creatures and we're
playing with the most efficient creature
removals because our mana is pretty
tight. We're not playing the big ram
spells like a lot of the other planes
walker decks do. Okay, now we talk about
mana. This is the most difficult part of
the deck to be honest because our
planaineswalkers are actually pretty
color inensive and we need to make woog
by turn four. So, pretty much every
single land is dedicated to color
fixing. They're loading up on the
fetches, shocks, duels, maybe even. Is
it possible to build this with a budget
mana base? Not the current list. The
current list is pretty greedy. And even
with the current setup, I sometimes
struggle with getting the right mana
always. So with different kinds of
lands, you will be one turn slower,
which I guess isn't the end of the
world, but the 1 2 3 4 curve is kind of
why I built this deck. Another option is
to focus your deck into three colors. I
guess blue, green, white, bent would be
the right choice here, and splash red
and black just for Tam's activation. I
haven't explored it too much, but at the
end of the day, this probably won't be a
budget list with cards like doubling
season and the planainesw walkers are
not always cheap. The deck is designed
to be pretty explosive. Yeah, we do have
to mulligan a bit to get the right hand
and because of this, I think it's good
to play somewhere between 38 to 40
lands. The manifixing alone makes this
deck not the most beginner friendly. On
turn one, you have to map out your next
three turns at least and play your lands
and fetch for lands accordingly. But if
things go according to plan, this deck
is pretty resilient. I mean the the
emblems are not removable. They stick
with you for the entire game. So
basically you're building up these epic
like resources that just they will
follow you around and you will
constantly have them as you play the
game. And that's such a unique thing to
have and because of that I think the
deck is moderately resilient. Now the
late game won't be amazing cuz your
planes walkers are are mediocre. Most of
them are pretty mediocre but yeah things
[clears throat] eventually kind of
balance out. It's it's a fun deck to
play but it's probably not the most
powerful. So again, the budget is very
high and I can't say I've tested this
list extensively. I've done a few rounds
online. It's been great. But yeah, make
sure you proxy it. Play this online.
Test it first before committing to
buying this deck. And I do have one game
changer in here. It's not necessary, but
I feel like this deck is bracket three.
Anyways, if you want some other game
changers like Tutors would be great,
Jessica's Will is great. Tefarious
Protection, why not? Yeah, there are
some decent options out there. Okay, and
there you have it. Now, let's go on to
our giveaway. Yes, it's still happening.
If you want to be involved, just be
subscribed and make a comment. Comment
about anything. But if you want to have
one extra chance, you can comment a
suggestion for this deck. And if you
don't want to wait or rely on Chance,
you can always head to Kakapo TCG's
website. They are my generous sponsor
and they have sweet products. And for
anyone buying, you can use my discount
code levels for 5% off all caps. And now
for the winner of my which video? The
Elda video. Yes, we have Red Fox.
Yeah, yeah, commenting suggesting City
of Death. I didn't end up taking the
suggestion. It's a cool card, but it's
it feels a bit wind and it's slow, so I
And again, deck slot is limited, but
doesn't matter cuz he won the giveaway
anyways for commenting. And for the
accepted wreck, we have Lilith, sorry,
Lilith the Catmoth. Yes, for suggesting
Wall of Roots. Now, that's a great
suggestion. This card is is nuts in in
Elder. I just missed it completely. So
yeah, please add my contact info or
leave a comment and we will arrange the
giveaway things and yeah, we have a lot
of new commanders coming out and yeah,
I'm looking to build at least four or
five from reality fracture along with
the unfinished business from mystery
boosters. So if you like this stuff,
please subscribe and stay tuned. It's
really really helpful to the channel.
Actually, if you're watching to this
point, that's already you've done so
much for me. Thank you so much. Thank
you. And yeah, I will see you in the
next